desde esta mañana hemos asistido a una
avalancha de reacciones a la muerte de
Silvio berlusconia aquí en Italia por
parte de italianos que recuerdan Las mil
facetas de berluscom y un personaje
político emprendedor figura transgresiva
que chocó al país con el escándalo del
bungabunga con jóvenes acusadas de
prostituirse a inicios de este año se
supo de su enfermedad sirvió verlos con
y sufría de una leucemia Crónica que
acabó con una carrera política que marcó
el país durante más de 30 años dirigió
cuatro gobiernos italianos entre
1994 y 2011 su herencia política es sin
duda la de haber fundado Forza Italia un
partido político de derecha que
inclusive hoy en día hace parte de la
actual coalición de gobierno y con la
desaparición de Silvio velozconi la
mayor incógnita política en Italia será
el destino de Forza Italia si el partido
logra sobrevivir con un nuevo líder o si
desaparecerá engullido por la
competencia habló de los partidos de la
derecha soberanista italiana como la
liga de Mateo salvini o fratelli Italia
el partido de Georgia melón y la actual
jefe del gobierno italiano